So, I told you earlier that sometimes
you might be the end user of your
own documentation.
I'm here with Art,
director of engineering here at Udacity.
So Art, tell me a horror story.
Tell me a time when you're
really kicking yourself for
not writing documentation.
>> That's a good question, Walter.
Feedbacks, early in my career.
I was doing a project for
a very sort of conservative stuffy
investment bank on Wall Street.
And I was doing the support
screen that comes up like,
if somebody that's using
the app needs help.
They click help and
it comes up with a phone number.
But we didn't yet have the phone number,
so like a placeholder phone number.
But I forgot to put in the read me,
that somebody needed to update
that before they shipped it.
So I just put in the first
thing that popped into my mind,
which was 1-900 of the name of
the company, we'll say, ABC-4EVA.
>> [LAUGH]
>> 4EVA, right?
>> Yeah.
>> And I shipped it, I collect my fee,
don't think anything of it.
Six months later, I get this frantic
call from the project manager.
Freaking out because one of their
customers had called the number,
nobody ever updated the help number.
This guy calls me up and he's like,
why did you put an adult 900 number
on the help screen of our app?
Because I had forgotten to document
that it was just a placeholder and
somebody in Utah updated it.
[CROSSTALK] [LAUGH]
>> No, God.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] That's not even a true story.
[LAUGH] You'd never do
something like that, right?
>> I know, I know.
Yeah, I would never.
>> What is-
[MUSIC]
>> I'm future Walter, and
I completely agree with
everything you just said, Art.
Present Walter over here forgot
to document the code on some
of the projects we've been working on.
And now, we can't seem to
remember what we were thinking.
>> Walter, I'm so disappointed.
[MUSIC]
>> Take a look at some of
your own older projects.
Can you remember everything that you
were thinking when you were writing
that code.
Wouldn't it be helpful to have a handy
reference of all the decisions that
past you made.